Is The Oracle’s guardian Seraph
an angel? Were Kid and Commander
Locke both casualties of war following The
Matrix Revolutions? How did the Analyst rise
to power? These are all questions that
could be answered in future spin-offs.
Though Trinity is killed at the end of the third
Matrix movie, she and Neo get a new chance at
life in The Matrix Resurrections, as it's later
revealed that the machines resurrected both of
them in order to support the Analyst's version of
the Matrix. Furthermore, Trinity goes through a
major development in the film when she learns
that she, too, now has the powers of the One.
While the first Matrix does provide some
clues to Trinity's past — explaining that
she was once a master hacker — not much else
has been revealed about her early days. But
a prequel could do a lot to fill in those
blanks. Carrie-Anne Moss has even teased
some of her own ideas about Trinity's
origins in interviews. For example,
she told GQ that she believes the character
was freed from the Matrix at an early age.
Trinity's greatest hacking triumphs
could be depicted in this spin-off,
along with her many encounters with
Agent Smith who, in Revolutions,
claims to have failed in capturing her more than
any other human. Alternately, while it's almost
a certainty that Trinity would be the co-star
of any potential follow-ups to Resurrections,
that doesn't mean she couldn't star
in a solo sequel adventure, too.
Originally portrayed by Laurence Fishburne,
Morpheus is a character who captures viewers'
attention every time he's on-screen —
and often when he's not. The captain
of the Nebuchadnezzar is everything
you'd want from a leader: wise, warm,
strong, and never without hope. Without Morpheus'
faith in the One, Neo might never have been freed
from the Matrix. And it's that same belief
that prevents further bloodshed in Zion
after he realizes Neo and the Machines have
allied against Agent Smith. That same faith,
however, can also be somewhat of an Achilles'
heel for Morpheus; in The Matrix Resurrections,
Niobe explains that it caused him to
underestimate the looming threat of the Analyst.
While Resurrections suggests Morpheus was a
casualty of the ensuing machine attack, that
movie sees Neo create a youthful, A.I. version
of his mentor, played by Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
"At last…"
The great thing about a possible Morpheus spin-off
is that there's already a fair amount of backstory
to work with. Elements from his past mentioned
in the Matrix comics could be expanded upon,
along with the beginning of his
relationship and falling out with
Niobe — not to mention his time as High
Chair of the Zion Council. Similarly,
the origins of Abdul-Mateen's half-Morpheus,
half-Smith replica could also be explored.
And a post-Resurrections spin-off starring that
version of Morpheus has a lot of promise, too.
Niobe is one of the undeniable standout
characters of the Matrix sequels,
and one of the patron saints of Matrix
spin-offs thanks to her star turn in the
2003 video game Enter the Matrix. A fearless
leader with a calm yet commanding presence,
she remains by far one of the best
contenders for a Matrix spin-off.
Being the only character from the original
resistance to appear in The Matrix Resurrections
other than Trinity and Neo, Niobe has a wealth of
story possibilities worth exploring. A spin-off
starring the character could explore her early
days in Zion or the original Matrix. Or, it could
reveal in detail the events that occurred between
Revolutions and Resurrections. More specifically,
it might focus on the formation of IO — Zion's
successor — and Niobe's rise to become its leader.
True to his name, Ghost doesn't appear as often
as his captain, Niobe, in the second and third
Matrix movies. But he gets an enormous amount of
screen-time in Enter the Matrix, in which he and
Niobe are the two playable characters. An avid
student of philosophy with a wry sense of humor
and an otherwise no-nonsense demeanor, Ghost would
be a great candidate for more Matrix spin-offs.
A prequel series to the original trilogy could
show how Ghost ends up joining Niobe on the Logos
and how he becomes such an expert shot, as well
as the origins of his unrequited crush on Trinity.
Conversely, a spin-off set after the first
three films could reveal what happened to
him in the more than 60-year gap before
Resurrections, including how he handles
the news of Trinity's demise. Perhaps his heroics
in Revolutions even earn him a ship of his own.
The Matrix's most notorious Agent,
Smith, proves you can't keep a bad
program down in Resurrections, in which
he's reincarnated in a new identity as
Thomas Anderson's boss and business partner.
Smith and Neo's mutual hatred of the Analyst
leads the two to briefly join forces near
the movie's end, and the notorious agent
lets his own boss know exactly how he
feels — by filling him with bullets.
Once Smith has accomplished his
objective, he leaves Neo and
Trinity to be hunted down by
the Analyst's legion of bots.
"You know the difference between
us, Tom? Anyone could have been you.
Whereas I've always been anyone."
This begs the question: Where did he go? A
Smith spin-off could answer that question,
showcasing his activities after Resurrections.
Just what plot will he come up with next to
fight the Architect and keep his freedom?
Will he be a friend or a foe when Neo and
Trinity decide to remake the Matrix, as they
promise to do at the end of Resurrections?
While future Matrix movies would
likely answer those questions,
a spin-off could surely delve further into the
details. Another option would be to explore
Smith's activities in the previous version
of the Matrix from the original trilogy,
which could allow Hugo Weaving to return to the
role. Better yet, a Smith project could go back
even further in time, revealing whether or not
the earlier iterations of the Matrix included
a version of Smith to balance out their versions
of the One — a subject of much debate among fans.
Bugs is the captain of the Mnemosyne in The Matrix
Resurrections, as well as the red pill who frees
Neo from the Matrix's latest reincarnation.
Brave, good-humored, and not one for following
orders when she feels they're wrong, Bugs would
be a perfect candidate for a Matrix spin-off.
Given how her Matrix extraction occurs
not long before she does the same for Neo,
it wouldn't be necessary to de-age the character
digitally for a prequel, provided it focuses on
Bugs as a young adult. Be it a prequel or sequel,
however, Jessica Henwick could easily slip back
into the role, and Resurrections shows that Bugs
is well-known for heading out on solo missions,
too. That said, the spin-off could also spotlight
her Mnemosyne crewmates to flesh them out further,
more clearly establishing how each
of them relates with their captain.
Though purged from the Matrix some time before
Resurrections, the Oracle is far from forgotten.
Morpheus tells Neo in The Matrix that the Oracle
has sided with Zion since the human rebellion
began. However, the Architect reveals in Reloaded
that her existence extends back even further,
as she helped him create the first successful
version of the machines' simulated reality.
Given that there have been seven versions
of the Matrix and the initial two failed,
the Oracle might have been around
as far back as the third Matrix,
meaning she has a wealth of
backstory ripe for exploration.
A prequel spin-off starring the Oracle
could answer many long-standing mysteries,
such as what the other iterations of the Matrix
were like, how she met her bodyguard Seraph,
and when she first rebelled against the Architect.
It could also feature Neo's predecessors, since
each Matrix the Oracle co-created also
contained its own version of the One.
The character would likely be recast, as her
original actor, Gloria Foster, passed away,
while her second actor, Mary Alice, hasn't worked
in entertainment media for some time. Not that a
sequel spin-off is out of the question, however.
The Merovingian does explain in Revolutions
that the Oracle can give her eyes to others.
Could she have passed them on to a successor?
The Matrix movies have dropped countless hints
about the mysterious program known as Seraph.
In The Matrix Revolutions, he's referred to as
"wingless" by one of the Merovingian's enforcers.
The Merv himself even reveals later on that the
two have a past association. While it's unclear
whether Seraph ever actually had wings, this clue,
as well as his white costume and Biblical name,
suggests he may have at one point been an
angel within the Matrix. This theory is
further supported when the Merovingian calls
him "the angel without his wings" in French.
Seraph may even be a Seraphim, who were
once the "Agents" of the paradise Matrix.
Interestingly, he almost starred in what
became the Matrix: Path of Neo video game.
Though that story wasn't to be, it doesn't mean
Seraph can't get another chance at a spin-off.
In addition to examining his true
nature and past with the Merovingian,
the spin-off could uncover why Seraph
is absent from the first Matrix movie,
despite the Oracle's claim that he's been her
bodyguard for some time. It could also depict his
battles with Agent Smith — whom, in Revolutions,
Seraph claims he has defeated in the past.
"You do not truly know
someone until you fight them."
Neo is always shown to be uncomfortable
with the hero worship he receives
from many of Zion's inhabitants, which
is one of the reasons he finds Kid
particularly difficult to be around. Since meeting
Neo on the day he freed himself from the Matrix,
Kid has idolized humanity's prophesied savior,
and he clearly states his intention to one day
serve aboard the Nebuchadnezzar — a prospect
nobody on the ship is too thrilled about. Still,
he proves to be a pretty remarkable person
himself in Zion's battle against the Machines
by helping Captain Mifune reload while fighting
off Sentinels. After a timely save from Zee,
he also gives the Hammer the
opening it needs to re-enter Zion.
Kid appears in The Matrix Online afterwards,
helming a ship fittingly called Neo's Hope.
Oddly, he's not present in Resurrections,
despite being significantly younger than most of
the major characters in the first three movies.
It's possible he was one of the many casualties
from the Machines' renewed war on Zion, of course,
but nobody can know for sure. A spin-off
could easily tie up this loose end, however,
and show Kid further coming into
his own as a hero after Revolutions.
Jason Lock is introduced in The Matrix Reloaded as
Morpheus' opposite. He's a hardened pragmatist who
neither believes in the One nor has any love lost
for Morpheus — the man who once dated his lover,
Niobe. Though arguably an effective tactician
and leader of Zion's forces in the real world,
Lock's disdain for Morpheus and his
beliefs often cloud his judgment,
causing him to repeatedly underestimate Neo's
importance in the war against the Machines.
Though he becomes an important figure in The
Matrix Online, Lock is not seen in Resurrections,
suggesting his relationship with Niobe at one
point ended for any number of reasons — perhaps
even his demise. A spin-off featuring
him could shed some light on his fate
and reveal whether or not his contentious
relationship with Morpheus improved after
Neo saved Zion. It would also be an opportunity
to humanize Lock and make him more sympathetic,
as he is somewhat of an antagonistic
figure in the original Matrix trilogy.
Who better to tell the full story of the Matrix
than the two programs who've seen them all? The
Architect alone created six versions of the
Matrix, aided by the Oracle in the later
versions. A spin-off starring him or both
characters could feature every iteration,
showing how they changed over time. Though the
Architect himself is certainly not an action hero,
he would have both the Seraphim and the
Agents to back him up on his adventures,
facing off against the Ones who existed before
Neo. This spin-off could also address whether
the Architect himself changed with each
new Matrix iteration. In the original
paradise version, for example, could
he have looked or dressed more like
artistic depictions of the Judeo-Christian
God? Similarly, could the Oracle's appearance
have resembled that of oracles of classical
antiquity, like those found in Ancient Greece?
The Analyst, meanwhile, has only created the
seventh Matrix, but that doesn't mean he's not
worthy of a spin-off of his own. Perhaps such a
film could show how he overthrew the Architect
in the first place. This would also provide
a good opportunity to elaborate on events
referenced in Resurrections, including his mass
purging of rebellious programs — which might
give some much-needed closure for characters
such as the Oracle, Rama Kandra, and Kamala.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.